no longer prime minister but muidan
yasin gets to be in the driver's seat
for a bit longer
the king has accepted his resignation
but appointed him as caretaker prime
minister until a successor is found
during my audience with the king i
submitted my resignation as prime
minister and on behalf of the entire
cabinet
under article 43 subsection 4 of the
federal constitution because i have lost
the confidence of the majority of
parliament
there had been questions about muyden's
legitimacy from the start he became
premier in march 2020 when he and
several members of parliament switched
sides and brought down the reformist
government that had ruled for less than
two years
this also allowed the united malays
national organization or amno a party
that was voted out in 2018
largely because of a multi-billion
dollar financial scandal to return to
power
since then the alliance known as
parikatan national has been plagued by
infighting partly because some amno
politicians felt they were being
sidelined
despite being part of the biggest party
in government
muridin has also been under pressure
because of his administration's handling
of the pandemic in january he advised
the king to declare a state of emergency
and suspend parliament
in june he placed the country under
lockdown yet malaysia has been reporting
record high coronavirus cases and deaths
last month hundreds of people gathered
on the streets of kuala lumpur demanding
moiyidin resign
now that that's happened there are
concerns the country will face a period
of political uncertainty
the king can decide on a new leader one
who he believes is likely to command the
confidence of the majority in parliament
but there is no obvious successor which
may pave the way for new alliances i
think this will push the opposition
pakitan harapan um no they need to talk
with each other and also prikhatan
national maybe they need to talk because
this is something that are not good not
only for the economy but also for the
pandemic the palace also said in a
statement on monday that holding
elections now is not feasible because of
the coronavirus epidemic in the country
florence louis al jazeera kuala lumpur